نرى انه لا يمكن تجاهل الصوره الاكبر يجب
ان نتطرق الى كيفيه انهاء الحرب في اسرع
وقت ممكن وكيفيه اطلاق سراح الرهائن
والسجناء
الفلسطينيين اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه
اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعلن مقتل ضابط وجندي وجرحى 66 اخرين في
معارك قطاع غزه خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يقول ان سحب
الجيش من مراكز حماس في غزه خطا فادح
وخطير وسيكلف اسرائيل ارواحا بشريه في
الاثناء اكد رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري وجوب العمل على انهاء الحرب في غزه
سريعا واطلاق الرهائن والسجناء
الفلسطينيين تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب
غزه في رابط التعليق الاول الحرس الثوري
الايراني يعلن قصف ما قال انها مقار تجسس
ت تابعه لارهابيين في اربيل شمال العراق
بصواريخ بالستيه الخارجيه الايرانيه تقول
ان الضربات دفاع عن الامن القومي في وجه
الارهاب والحكومه العراقيه تندد بالقصف
وتقول انه استهدف مدنيين وتؤكد انها
ستتقدم بشكوى لمجلس الامن وتسلم القائمه
بالاعمال الايراني ببغداد مذكره احتجاج
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يدعو الى تغيير وضع
جارته الجنوبيه في دستور بلاده الى دوله
منفصله ومعاد متهما سول بالسعي الى هدم
النظام وجهود الوحده من جهه اخرى انتقد
رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه الخطوه وتعهد بالرد
على استفزازات بيونج يانج بشكل مضاعف
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي يفوز بجائزه افضل
لاعب في العالم خلال حفل توزيع جوائز ذا
بيست المقدمه من الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم عن عام
2023 متفوقا بذ على النرويجي هلند
والفرنسي مبابي في حين فاز الاسباني بيب
جوارديولا مدرب مانشستر سيتي الانجليزي
بجائزه افضل مدرب الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء